so the top tennessee public health
official is very upset that people are
not
listening to her demands
and so she is now claiming that she was
sent a threatening package
she is the top vaccine official in
tennessee michelle fiskus she is
claiming that she was sent
a muzzle
this was one week before she was fired
from her position
that's pretty bad so then there was an
investigation into this taken up by the
tennessee department of safety and
homeland security and you know what i
found out
found out that
michelle fiskus sent the package to
herself
and this happens
so
so
often
not just with claims
from public health people but with
people who are claiming racist attacks
people claiming sexist attacks
time and time and time again it turns
out to be a hoax perpetrated by the
people themselves jesse smolette this
woman the top tennessee health former
top tennessee health doctor
health uh official rather
is the the jessie smolet
of tennessee
sending the package to herself it's it
wasn't even hard to find it out it was
an amazon account open that she opened
up and it was purchased on a credit card
in her name
states that the case was closed on
monday victimhood carries a great deal
of currency
i'm glad you liked that clip i would
strongly encourage you go subscribe to
the michael knowles show podcast on
apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher wherever you get your podcast
just go just head on over there right
now and click subscribe
then leave a five star review appreciate
that and then you can get this full
episode which is about the friendly
peaceful taliban takeover we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]